>> From the library of
congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Karen Lloyd: Good afternoon.
What a panel of experts
we have here today?
So I think everybody's
in for a real treat.
I'm Karen Lloyd, Director of
the Veterans History Project
and it's my pleasure to welcome
you to the most beautiful building
in Washington, D.C. On the wall
in the Veterans History Project
Information Center, which is located
across the street in the Madison
building is a Maya Angelou quote,
which perhaps you've heard
before, "There is no greater agony
than bearing an untold
story inside you."
Monday is Memorial
Day, a day I hope,
before everyone starts their
festivities, they take a minute
to remember those who gave
their lives in service
to our country, the
ultimate sacrifice.
We should also be mindful that
many who returned home from war
and military service did
not come back unscathed
and that's why we are
gathered here today.
Post-traumatic stress disorder,
PTSD, the invisible wound
that affects hundreds of veterans.
Over 30% of Vietnam
veterans and 10% of Iraq
and Afghanistan veterans
experience PTSD.
But it's not just the
combat vets who are at risk.
Sexual assault and trauma can also
produce this debilitating disorder.
PTSD can impact a veteran's ability
to work, to interact with friends
and family, just to live.
While it's a -- while
it's a major factor
in veterans becoming involved --
and it's also a major factor
with veterans becoming involved
with our justice system.
While we are participating
in the Veterans History Project
cannot cure veterans of PTSD,
we hear from veterans
and experts alike
that say unburdening the weight of
their story provides some relief.
At the Veterans History Project we
make veterans' experiences available
to researchers so they
can be better understood.
We hold events like this to let
veterans know they are not alone,
to raise awareness of programs such
as the Veterans Treatment Court,
that positive creative
outcomes for veterans with PTSD.
Today you are -- you will hear
plenty of ideas and experiences
about PTSD and Veterans
Treatment Courts,
but those ideas will be useless
if they stay in this room.
I hope you will learn something
from this panel and take it with you
and use it to make a difference
in someone's life,
even if in a small way.
June is National PTSD
Awareness Month, a perfect time
to get involved whether
it's volunteering
with a veteran's service
organization
or interviewing the veteran
in your life for VHP.
Again, we appreciate you choosing
to be here today to learn more
about PTSD and how we
can support our veterans.
It is now my pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker,
CNN's very own Chief Washington
Correspondent, Mr. Jake Tapper.
[ Applause ]
>> Jake Tapper: Thank you so much
for innovating me to speak before
such an important group of people
having such a crucial conversation.
Um, I did not serve, but I
cover people who did and who do.
Uh, it is -- uh -- the honor
and responsibility of --
of what I do to tell these stories.
Uh, and it is the honor
of a lifetime to do so.
Um, I thought that, uh, the best
thing I could contribute, um,
to this event would be to tell you
about a young man named Private
Ed Faulkner Jr. Um, that maybe,
through his story, people could come
to understand some of the struggles
and some of the reasons why PTSD,
uh, exacts the toll that it does
and why people have such a difficult
time figuring out how to fix it.
Um, Ed Faulkner Jr. Was
from North Carolina.
He served with 3-61
Cav and he was one
of the many heroes
during the October 3rd,
2009 attack on Combat
Outpost Keating.
Um, I wrote a book
about the outpost.
Um, and the book focuses
quite a bit on, uh,
the heroes who did not make it home.
Um, but Ed, uh, is a hero who
made it home, um, but was not able
to leave the battle behind him.
And I thought just
sharing his story might --
might help illuminate the
conversation in some small degree.
Uh, after the battle where
Ed was wounded, um --
he was actually bummed out -- he
had a Purple Heart from serving
in Iraq and, during the, uh, intense
battle of Combat Outpost Keating,
he was wounded again in the
same spot and he was bummed
because he was, um, going
to have two Purple
Hearts, but only one scar.
Uh, which he thought was not fair.
Um, but after the battle, he was
sent to recuperate at Fort Carson
in Colorado where his wounds were
treated -- his physical wounds.
He was promoted to, um,
Private Second Class
and he was initially encouraged
to rejoin his team in Afghanistan.
Um, an officer asked him, "Don't
you want to be a real man and return
to Afghanistan with your unit?"
But Faulkner, um, said
something that a lot
of his fellow soldiers
didn't think was brave, but,
in retrospect, was very brave.
Um, he admitted that he
didn't think he was capable
of going back into war.
Um, he had too much going
on in his head, he said,
too many voices, uh,
intense nightmares.
An Army physician told him that he
had post-traumatic stress disorder.
He was all ready to be fair
to the Army and had come
into the Army all ready,
um, something, uh -- uh --
in something of a precarious -- uh
-- an unstable place emotionally.
Um, but the battle at Combat
Outpost Keating had tipped him
into a chiasm chasm of sorts.
He lost two of his best friends,
Michael Scuuza and Chris Griffin,
um, during an attempt, uh, to
save, uh, five men who were trapped
in a Humvee during the battle.
Um, he, Griffin, another guy
named Sergeant Joshua Hart, uh,
had tried to rescue them stuck
in a Humvee and another Humvee.
At the end of the day, of the
three men in the rescue truck
and the five men in the
Humvee that was trapped, um,
only three of them survived.
Um, and Faulkner was one of them.
And he had, as a lot of people
have, um, survivor's guilt.
Faulkner's commander
at Fort Carson, um,
had already suspected
he was self-medicating,
um, with illegal drugs.
Um, which he thought
was contributing
to what he was going through.
He decided it would be better
to discharge Faulkner, um,
before he got in so much
trouble that he was, um,
dishonorably discharged
or even court-martialed.
Um, the decision upset Ed's
father, Ed Faulkner Sr., um,
who reached out to his congressman.
Um, his son needed
psychological therapy,
not humiliation, the dad said.
But the Army thought that they were
doing Ed Faulkner Jr. a favor, um,
by kicking him out in a way that he
would be able to preserve his access
to the VA and his benefits.
So, April 1st, 2010, Ed Faulkner Jr.
and Ed Faulkner Sr. boarded a plane,
um, back home to North Carolina.
As soon as Ed Faulkner Jr. got
back to Burlington, North Carolina,
he retreated into his own head.
Um, he did keep in touch with some
of his friends through Facebook,
but he described himself as haunted.
He dreamt about Iraqis coming to his
family's door, ringing the doorbell,
bringing their dead babies to him.
He lamented to his father that
he could have done something
to save his friend Chris Griffin's
life, but was not able to.
When the son was out, he
would have flashbacks.
When the moon was out, he was
scared awake by nightmares.
Michael Scuuza, his
friend, had once been able
to comfort Faulkner whenever he
was having a tough time saying,
"It's all good, man.
It's all good," but
Scuuza was now gone
and wasn't able to say that anymore.
In April, 2010, Faulkner
started in a carpet cleaning job.
He would get up at 6:00am every day.
His boss showed him how to use
the cleaning system on his van.
When Faulkner stepped into a
bucket of scalding hot water,
he said the blisters hurt
worse than his bullet wound,
but he was trying -- he was
trying to make a life for himself.
But the outpost always never left Ed
Faulkner Jr. He would stay up late
at night watching the videos
that the insurgents
had posted on YouTube.
Uh, he told a friend from
3-61 that he heard gunfire
and saw Taliban every day.
His father took him to a Greensboro
Grasshoppers minor league baseball
game on the 4th of July.
When the fireworks started,
Faulkner hit the ground
as if he was under attack.
Once in the middle of the night
Faulkner's mom could not find him.
He wasn't in his bed.
His truck was still in
the driveway, though.
He didn't answer his cell phone.
She got in her car in
the middle of the night,
drove around the neighborhood
looking for him.
He wasn't anywhere.
When she returned, as she pulled
into the driveway, she saw a shadow
in the bushes in front of the house.
She walked over and she found
her son crouched down acting
as if he had a rifle and as if
he were looking through its scope
as an enemy -- at an
enemy across the street.
He picked up an invisible
radio and started talking
to it -- into it as if in combat.
She guided him to his bed.
The next morning, he
remembered none of it.
At the end of July 2010
Ed Faulkner Jr. ran naked
into the street yelling that
the end of the world was coming.
He stopped cars and asked
drivers if they had been saved,
if they had accepted Jesus
Christ as their lord and savior.
He was picked up by local police
who called his sister,
Sara Faulkner Minor.
She told them that her brother
had recently been discharged
from the Army, had two
Purple Hearts, one from Iraq,
one from Afghanistan, he
had shrapnel injuries,
and he was suffering from PTSD.
"I knew it," said the police
officer, "When we detained him,
he was talking on the radio to
fellow soldiers who weren't there."
Both were imaginary, of course,
the soldiers and the radio.
The officer said that the police
did not want to arrest Faulkner.
They would commit him.
Sara agreed.
She didn't want him to hurt
himself or anyone else.
So she visited him at
the psychiatric wing
of Alamance Medical
Center in North Carolina.
At first, she walked right past his
room because his mattress was thrown
to the floor, the occupant
inside was covered
from head to toe by a sheet.
The room clearly belonged
to somebody else,
not her brother, somebody unhinged.
"Whoever that is, bless his heart,"
she said to herself
before realizing it was Ed.
And she walked in.
She tried to make conversation.
It didn't sound like
his voice when he spoke.
Something had taken him over.
He scared her.
He said to her, "I can't
sit in this nuthouse."
The realization knocked
the wind out of her.
She said, "My brother
is very ill right now."
He said, "This is the end for me.
You have no idea how I feel.
I'm so stressed out.
I don't know why I did what I did.
I don't know why it happened."
She tried to tell him to
give his life over to God,
that only God could
save him, not drugs.
But, to her, her brother
seemed beyond saving.
"There's all this noise in my
mind," he told her, "It won't stop.
It won't quiet down."
Faulkner was transferred to
a local veteran's hospital
for a couple of days.
He was assigned a social worker
and then he was discharged.
His parents were not
impressed by the quality
of care their son received.
It all seemed very casual.
It all seemed very oblivious.
He clearly needed some serious help.
His father would say, "If you're
out in a storm, you seek shelter.
Ed has a storm going
on in his brain."
But his government, his
country provided his son
with no such shelter.
Faulkner soon met a woman
named Sharleen in August.
She told him that she was bipolar,
she suffered from manic depression.
For the first time in a long
time, Faulkner did not feel alone.
He had Sharleen.
She knew how he felt.
She had a young daughter.
He helped her with her homework,
a normal life, or almost.
He moved into her two
bedroom apartment
within weeks of meeting her.
She was on government assistance.
She lived in subsidized
housing provided
through the Burlington
Housing Authority.
She was prescribed asserted
medications including Methadone
and Xanax.
She'd been investigated a
few times by local police
for selling the narcotics
that she had been prescribed.
To Ed's family, all of this
seemed cause for alarm,
but he was unyielding,
"I don't have to live
in the biggest house," he said.
"I don't need life's finest.
So what if she's on welfare?
So what if she's in
government housing?
These people are closest to God."
Sharleen got on the phone
one time with Ed's sister.
"I love your brother,"
she told Sara.
She seemed space out -- spaced out.
Her voice was rambling.
"I can tell you're on
drugs," Sara replied.
"Lock them up.
My brother was once
addicted to pain pills.
Keep them out of his reach."
Sharleen promised that she would.
After all, she had a little girl.
She had to keep her medications
out of her hands as well.
On the night of September
15th, 2010,
Sharleen found Ed Faulkner
Jr. drifting off to sleep
in his parked truck
behind the steering wheel.
When she asked him what was
wrong, he didn't answer.
She helped him stumble out of
the vehicle and into her bed.
The next morning, Sharleen woke up
and got her daughter
ready for school.
She took her to the bus stop.
When she came back, she
was surprised to see
that Ed hadn't moved an inch.
She realized he wasn't breathing.
She called 9-1-1.
She tried to revive him.
The fire department
arrived, took over the CPR.
The first responders noticed
that there were several buckets
of murky water in the hallway.
It wasn't clear whether the
apartment had functioning
electricity or plumbing.
The mattress on which Ed
Faulkner Jr. was lying was riddled
with cigarette burns.
The apartment was packed with
piles of clothing and trash.
The bathroom was coated in filth.
The police and ambulance
got there at the same time.
The emergency medical
technicians ran in
and confirmed what the
firefighters already ascertained.
Ed Faulkner Jr. Was dead.
They put him on a stretcher.
They wheeled him out.
They placed in the
back of the ambulance
and they sped off to
the emergency room.
An autopsy indicated his cause of
death was acute methadone toxicity.
A few days later, a Veterans
Administration Office worker called
Ed Faulkner Sr. "Would you please
let your son know he's late
for his appointment?"
he asked. As word of Ed
Faulkner Jr.'s death spread,
his former sergeant, Jonathon
Hill, called Tye Carter,
another fellow soldier from 3-61 Cav
to discuss how thoroughly the Army
and then the VA had turned
their backs on their friend.
Tye Carter, who would later be
awarded the Medal of Honor said,
"I kind of think Ed was the
9th victim of COP Keating
and I honestly don't
think he'll be the last."
There needs to be a
place in American society
for the Ed Faulkner
Jr.'s of the world.
I don't have the solutions.
I'm a reporter.
I'm not a policy maker.
But whether it's in the Army or in
the VA or in our local communities,
they are not somebody
else's problem.
They are not somebody in the street
just blocking you from getting
to work when you want
to get to work.
They are our problem.
That we are not doing
enough to save men
like Ed Faulkner Jr.
is a national disgrace.
I'm going to now introduce
Major General Clyde Tate
and Melissa Fitzgerald.
Returned Major General Butch Tate is
Former Deputy Judge Advocate General
for the United States
Army and now Chief Council
for the National Association
of Drug Court Professionals
and Justice for Vets.
He currently service as
Special Advisor for Military
and Veteran Affairs to the president
of the American Bar Association.
Melissa Fitzgerald was an
actor best known for her role
in the TV series The West Wing.
She left Hollywood to
lead Justice for Vets,
a division of the National
Association
of Drug Court Professionals where
she will not be expanding her role
to head up a new initiative
called Advancing Justice.
I want to thank you for taking
the time for listening to my story
about Ed Faulkner Jr. and I hope
that this meeting today helps
prevent future tragedies
from happening.
It's been my honor.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Melissa Fitzgerald:
Well, thank you, Jake,
for all that you do
on behalf of veterans.
You really -- do incredible work.
[ Applause ]
And I'd also like to
thank Greg Crawford, um,
who is here on the panel, uh, from
National Institute of Corrections
for inviting us to
join in today's event.
And I appreciate your
efforts and National Institute
of Corrections' support of
veterans who are involved
in the criminal justice system.
It has been the greatest honor of my
life to be part of Justice for Vets,
an organization that is having a
profound impact and real impact
on the lives of veterans
and their families.
I'm excited to expand
my role, um, and --
and launch the new initiatives
of Advancing Justice.
I think we all know that our
veterans are among our nation's
greatest and most valuable
civic assets.
They are the backbone of American
society instilled with the --
the values that most
of us aspire to, honor,
duty, leadership, respect.
We know that the vast majority of
our nation's veterans return home
as leaders, part of their
communities, and valued members
of our communities
leading exemplary lives.
We also know that everyone's
journey home is not the same
and some will struggle.
We cannot ignore the fact that one
in five returning veterans suffers
from PTSD and one and six suffers
from a substance use disorder.
We cannot ignore the debilitating
effect of traumatic brain injuries
and other trauma related injuries
on the lives of military families.
We cannot ignore that these
issues often lead to homelessness,
unemployment, arrest, or worse.
If we do not intercept
these vulnerable veterans
at the key moments of crisis, we
may not have another opportunity.
Instead of sending
our veterans to jail,
Veterans Treatment Courts ensure
that the veterans who struggle
with the transition home become
involved in the justice system
with a substance use disorder
and/or mental health condition
or trauma receive the structured
treatment and mentoring they need
to get their lives back on track.
Veterans Treatment
Courts give our veterans
who defended our freedoms
the opportunities to fight
for their own freedoms,
freedoms from addiction,
freedoms from mental anguish,
freedom from unemployment,
freedom from homelessness,
and freedom from isolation.
Veterans Treatment Courts recognize
that restoring our veterans
to healthy citizens not
only honors their sacrifice,
but it makes our communities
stronger.
And Veterans Treatment Courts work.
They work by reducing crime.
They work by saving the taxpayer
a tremendous amount of money.
And they work by returning health
veterans to our communities
where we greatly need it -- they
are needed and where they belong.
At Justice for Vets
it is our mission
to put a veteran's
treatment court within reach
of every veteran in need.
Justice for Vets is the only
national organization committed
and dedicated to the expansion
of veteran's treatment courts.
And I am happy to say that
today there are 15,000 veterans
who would otherwise be incarcerated
who are receiving life-saving
treatment in the
over 330 veteran's treatment
courts across the country.
And, with that, I will
turn it over to you, Butch.
>> Clyde Tate: Thanks, Melissa.
Let me just briefly add my
thanks for the opportunity to be
with you today and to offer
my thanks to all of you
for joining this conversation,
a conversation
that our nation must have about
providing a holistic solution
to the challenges facing
some of our veterans.
When a veteran and his or her
conduct brings them into contact
with law enforcement and eventually
our criminal justice system,
our nation, we, have a choice,
a choice between placing them
in a criminal justice system
that may not have the capacity
or the capability to consider their
unique experiences and challenges
and a system where we are
likely to see them again,
or we can make the
choice that because
of their service we are placing them
in a criminal justice environment
where the unique background
and experiences are understood,
where the system melds treatment
with intensive supervision all aimed
at improving outcomes, in
other words placing them
in a veterans treatment court.
Veterans Treatment Courts, if
you're not familiar with that model,
are a form of problem solving
courts akin to drug courts,
which number in excess of 3,500,
and really have been a part
of our jurisprudence since 1989.
Problem solving courts like DUI
courts, women's drug courts,
domestic violence and mental
health courts, to name but a few,
all of which were created to
address the specific needs
and appreciate the unique
experiences of their population.
But it wasn't until 2008 when a
courageous judge and his staff
in Buffalo, New York
recognized more could be done
to improve the outcomes of veterans
in their criminal justice
system and a movement began.
They chose, again,
a matter of choice,
they chose to do something different
and started the conversation,
a conversation today, which all
of us are privileged to continue.
Now I've been a part of these courts
since I retired from the Army three
and a half years ago and
the Army taught me to kind
of be a bottom line,
up front person.
I have, however, spared you
the use of PowerPoint today.
But my bottom line up front is this,
I believe that veterans
treatment courts, our government,
the judiciary, and the community
at their very, very finest moment.
In trying times, if you want
to believe in something,
I urge you to choose
to believe in the value
of the veteran's treatment courts.
Now, there are a couple
of distinguishing features
of these courts that
I'll highlight for you,
special ingredients if you will.
The use of volunteer
veteran mentors who choose
to be a part of these courts.
Trust me, no one responds
to a veteran like a veteran.
No one cares for a veteran
like another veteran.
They become their battle buddies.
The other special ingredient,
veteran's justice outreach officers.
A great new story for the
Department of Veteran Affairs.
These VJOs, as they're
called, sit in court
and almost instantly connect the
justice involved veteran to benefits
and services that they
may not otherwise pursue.
But why do I urge you
to choose these courts?
As my colleague, my battle buddy,
my teammate Melissa
said, because they work.
The data is now showing what we have
known anecdotally for some time,
that trauma focused treatment
combined with the support
of veteran mentors improves
outcomes dramatically
for our justice involved veterans.
And, importantly, these
courts restore home.
They unlock potential.
And they promote a
lifestyle of recovery.
And as a nation are we really going
to choose anything
less for our veterans?
I hope not.
I'm grateful for our panels
today and the information you're
about to get from them who will
give up their time and expertise
to help us better understand
and, thus,
treat one of the unique
challenges facing some
of our veterans and that is PTSD.
The more we know and
the more we understand,
the more lives we can change,
the more lives we can save.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Melissa Fitzgerald: Now,
before we share a video
from the National Institute
of Collections' live broadcast
on veterans treatment courts,
um, you know, I'd like to say
that this video will
highlight the struggles
that some of our veterans face.
I think it is very important
for all of us to remember,
as we watch the video and
throughout today's conversation,
as I said before, that
the vast majority
of our veterans are strengthened
by their military service
and they are returning
home truly as civic assets.
And one characteristic that
all of our veterans share,
including the ones who are
struggling, is one of resilience.
When given the structure, the
treatment, and the mentoring
in veteran's treatment courts,
the veterans who are participating
in these programs thrive.
They too return home to our
communities where they are valuable,
valuable members of our communities,
leaders, and civic assets.
And what has been remarkable to see
in the past three and a half years
of traveling around the country and
getting to know the men and women
who participate in these veterans'
treatment court programs is
that they are of the finest men
and women I have ever encountered.
And I am humbled to know them.
I am honored to work
on their behalf.
And watching how grateful
they are for the second chance
and how committed they are
to giving back proves to all
of us every day why these
programs are so greatly needed.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
[ Heavy Breathing ]
[ Yelling ]
[ Yelling and Gunfire ]
>> I went into a great
depression and anxiety.
But I still felt like
I was all alone.
No one understood my situation.
Uh, just -- just bummed
out with no place to go.
Just really, really depressed.
Fell into a real, real
deep depression.
>> I wanted everything to end.
I wanted to get revenge.
I wanted to die.
>> I'm diagnosed with
PTSD and other disorders.
>> I was dealing with suicidal
thoughts, suicidal attempts.
>> I got arrested for domestic
violence, uh -- uh -- two assaults.
>> I ended up catching
my first case --
my first legal case where I was
looking at two years in prison.
>> When I returned home from Vietnam
in 1968 I had no idea what
post-traumatic stress disorder was.
I just thought, hey, everything's
normal and I was drinking a lot.
>> I got into drinking and, you
know, and the stuff that goes
with that, kind of acting
out, being very reckless.
I was addicted to drugs.
I was drinking a lot.
I was making bad decisions and, um,
basically it all caught up with me.
>> My drinking picked up.
You know? And pretty much
spiraled out of control.
And my lowest point
was, uh, I was homeless.
I -- I lived in my
truck for three months.
I got my 3rd DUI and I ended
up in Boone County Jail.
>> I tell a lot of people
the hardest part about going
over there is coming back home,
reconnecting with friends,
everybody changed over the
course of me being gone.
And, I don't know, I felt
like a stranger coming back.
>> The friends you make
in the civilian world,
although they are really
great friends,
they're not like the friends
you have in the Marine Corps.
And when you're in the
Marine Corps it's a --
it's a sisterhood and a brotherhood.
>> One of my really
good friends was killed.
I mean it really devastated me.
I wanted nothing to do with
anybody, but, you know,
crawl into a bottle and go drink.
>> There was this young girl,
maybe about 16, 17 years old
and she was a catch year.
And I saw her in my
mind wearing a burqa.
Instantly I wanted to punch her.
And I remember shooking my shoe left
to right and I tapped on the floor
and I said, "This isn't sand
and this isn't dirt and I'm not
in another country somewhere."
[ Music ]
>> Jonathan Elias: Good afternoon.
I'm Jonathan Elias.
I'm a news anchor over at
ABC 7 News here in town,
which I hope every single one of
you watch every day religiously.
Um, but I'm also an
adjunct professor
at the US Army War College.
My experience with veterans, I've
worked with them for over a decade.
And it started about 12 years ago
when I started a program called
the Welcome Home Project.
It was a simple thing and in my
mind I just thought it was one
of those things I wanted to do.
I just wanted to give a handshake
and a hug to veterans coming home
who had received a Purple
Heart just to tell them,
"It's good to have you home.
We love you.
You're valued."
And, you know, you hear about PTSD.
I was a history student in college
and so I'd studied World War II
and they didn't call
it PTSD at that time.
They just called it people who
were remote or maybe they drank,
whatever it was they
-- they were escapists.
But I'll never forget
the first ceremony I had
where we had these baskets and we
had a couple hundred people show
up to give them hugs and handshakes
and it was a young,
good looking corpsman.
And he just walked up to me.
He was as normal as could be and
he said, "Why are you doing this?"
And I said, "Well, it's
the right thing to do."
And all of a sudden he started
to shake and he gave me a hug
and he started to sob in my arms.
And that was my first real brush
with PTSD of understanding that,
you know, here I am celebrating
these spirits that had seemed
to be untouched and unbroken by war,
and yet these spirits not only were
touched, they were being shattered.
In some. And, again, it has
to be emphasized it is some.
And I knew from that day on that
there's more that needs to be done.
There's a story that
needs to be told.
And it is our problem to fix.
These are our warriors
we're sending off to protect
and preserve our freedoms.
The least we can do is
try and figure it out.
The best I can tell is -- and from
talking to a number of veterans,
if you've never been in combat, if
you've never experienced combat,
then it's impossible for
you to truly understand it.
And one veteran who's put
it as plainly as he could,
he was with the unit in infantry,
he said, "in a five minute period
in my lifetime I walked
into a situation
and all I remember smelling
was gun smoke and gun powder
and hearing mortars going off, and
seeing three of my friends dead
on the ground, or at
least pieces of them."
I don't know how you
translate that to people
who have never experienced combat
and then expect them to come home
and then obey a traffic light
and have baseball games
playing on the background.
Those are the kinds of things that
are very difficult if not impossible
to transition, but that
really is the goal.
And having resources and experts
like you see here in front of you,
that is -- at least to get
the conversation going --
they've been having the conversation
a long time, but perhaps some
of the audience who are
policy makers or have access
to do something about this, perhaps
then we've done something today
or we'll accomplish something today.
So, let's start with
introducing the panel.
I'll have them introduce themselves.
They'll tell you their name.
They'll tell you what
they've been doing.
Give it a couple minutes each.
Greg, let's start with you.
>> Greg Crawford: Thanks, John.
Hi, I'm Greg Crawford.
I'm a veteran US Air Force.
I'm also currently a
correctional program specialist
at the National Institute
of Corrections.
And, first, I want to thank those
that have served our country and,
more importantly, some of those who
have continued to serve by serving
as volunteer veteran peer mentors
in veteran's treatment
courts across the country.
We appreciate your service.
I also want to thank John -- Andrew
Huber and the Library of Congress
for giving us this opportunity,
Jake Tapper for taking time
out of his day to come see us,
and especially our colleagues
over there, Melissa
Fitzgerald and Butch Tate,
very much appreciate both of you.
Um -- uh -- and Jonathon, thank
you for serving as moderator today
and for the work that you do
on the Welcome Home Project.
And, uh, as a runner,
I also appreciate
that you were the only reporter
sitting on the finish line
at the Boston Marathon bombing.
Um, after my service,
I was able to go
on to complete my bachelor's degree
at Washington State University
and my master's degree
at Chapman University.
I started my professional
career in mental health.
I went on to serve 11 years in
Pierce County District Court, um,
as a probation officer
and supervisor, director,
and manager of alternative programs.
Came to NIC in 2012 and,
shortly after my arrival,
my former supervisor and
former director of the agency,
Jim Cosby walked by my office
one day and he says, "Greg,
I want you to do something
about veterans," and he sent me
to the Executive Health
Council meeting
that was chaired by Dr. Tom Berger.
I attended that meeting and I --
in between presentations, I came up
and introduced myself
and we got to talking.
He says, "You know, you
got to meet Bernie Edelman.
And the three of us met at Union
Station in Washington, D.C. here
and we started scribbling
down ideas on napkins.
And, uh, four site visits, three
national conferences to Justice
for Vets National Conference,
and lots of interviews later we
produced Veterans Treatment Courts
as a second chance for vets
who have lost their way.
And this publication, um, some
of you may have gotten a copy of,
really served as the
platform for a lot
of our veteran's initiatives at NIC.
And we'll get into that
a little bit today.
Um, I'd be remiss if I didn't
thank the National Institute
of Corrections leadership for their
support of veterans initiatives
and also to, uh, our editor
at NIC, Donna Leadbetter,
who has taken up an interest
in veterans initiatives
and was responsible for
connecting us to Andrew Huber.
So, um, we're looking forward
to discussing what we're working
on at NIC and I'll
pass it over to Bernie.
>> Bernie Edelman: Good handoff.
I'm Bernie Edelman.
I'm assent Brooklyn, New York.
I grew up in a public
housing project in Canarsie.
Uh, which politely is called
the armpit of the borough.
Uh, if my housing projects of about
10,000 souls was its own little
city, uh, we would have
been mourning the deaths
of about 10 guys in Southeast Asia.
Um, I got drafted, conscripted,
right after I got out of college.
I spent most of 1970 halfway around
the world in a place called Vietnam,
which keeps coming
back to me and one
of the reasons I'm
doing what I'm doing.
Um, I participated in the
first veterans art show
in Saint Paul, Minnesota.
Brought the show to New York City.
Did a piece for the Daily News
Sunday Magazine I didn't bill
them for.
We had 1,500 people
on opening night,
650 a day coming in
to see this stuff.
Uh, and about 15% of the work sold,
which helped the artists themselves.
Uh, that led to my
appointment by Mayor Ed Koch
who was the first public official,
elected official to put his money
where his mouth was and
actually help Vietnam veterans.
I think -- I know I owe
him a debt of gratitude.
And, um, on the New York Vietnam
Veterans Memorial Commission,
I served on a committee that
chose the design for the memorial.
And that was the basis for
this book, Dear America:
Letters Home from Vietnam, which I
did in about 10 weeks with seven,
eight weeks of fine tuning.
Did it for the commission.
Uh, HBO did a film
based on this book.
Um, won them two of their
first three Emmys ever.
We then did a documentary short that
was nominated for an Academy Award.
Uh, meanwhile I was named the first
Director of the Mayor's Office
of Veterans Affairs for
the city of New York.
Did that until Ed left his
job and Bernie left his.
Uh, I did some other things,
but Vietnam keeps coming back.
I'm a writer, a photographer,
an editor.
Um, I've done a couple of
other books and I consider, uh,
the second chance to
be one of the books.
When I met Greg and he
asked me to do something,
I think he was thinking of,
you know, a 16 page brochure,
short booklet, about how to
do a veterans treatment court.
I told him I would do something
unlike any government publication
and I think we succeeded on that.
I gave him 40,000 words, uh,
and a lot of it in the words
of the folks we spoke with, uh,
together, Doc Berger, myself, Greg.
It was, you know, a
hell of an experience.
Uh, I was so impressed, so taken
by the sense of commitment,
the eloquence, of the folks we spoke
with whether they were graduates
of the veteran's treatment
court, whether they worked
in a veterans treatment court.
Uh, and they told their
stories beautifully.
And this is something
that has stuck with me
and I see deserves all the credit in
the world for doing a lot of stuff
to help justice involved veterans.
They formed the Justice Involved
Veterans Network, folks who were
in the field and myself serve
on it, and we hope to do things
that will effect policy not only
on a national level, but from state
to state to state because
veterans today choose
to serve in the military.
Uh, no longer is anyone conscripted.
Uh, it's not an accident of birth
that you serve in the military.
We owe something to those who serve.
And if they get in trouble
with the law and get caught
up in the great maw of the
criminal justice system,
we have to do everything we can to
help them divert from imprisonment,
help them get their lives
together, or if they are imprisoned,
help them when they get out with
mentors, help them re-acclimate
to the society that a lot of
folks feel has abandoned them.
With that, Doc.
>> Judge.
>> Bernie Edelman: Oh, judge.
>> Vance Peterson: OK [laughing].
Thank you.
I'm Vance Peterson.
I'm a District Court
Judge in Spokane.
I've been on the bench for 26
years and during the course of most
of that time I also served 29
years active reserve and guard.
Unlike Bernie I was not in
the projects of New York.
I grew up on a small ranch
about five miles south
of Canada in Washington State.
And when I was 18 the
choice was, at that time --
I wanted an education badly --
our high school at that time had
lost five individuals in Vietnam.
That was not a consideration,
of course, when you're 18.
So the choice for me was to follow
a long standing family tradition
of enlisting in the
Marine Corps, uh,
which everybody in my family was.
Or -- and one day I got an
envelope from the Army saying,
"congratulations, you have
a four year ROTC scholarship
to Gonzaga University, home of
the Gonzaga Bulldogs," and I took
that opportunity and went to
-- to -- to school at Gonzaga.
After that I served four
years on active duty.
I had four years -- about two and a
half to three years in the infantry
and was lucky enough to get
involved in special forces,
went to the special
forces qualification course
after ranger school, and ended up at
28 years of service at the age of --
in 2003, at the age of 50 being
told by the reserve and guard,
"Well, you're too old now.
You didn't make full
colonel so you're out."
So I kind of just went
back to being a judge,
which is what I was doing
for a living anyway.
About 2000 -- I think it was the
fall of 2009, we started seeing,
on our bench, an influx of primarily
young males, but some young females,
who were coming in with really no
criminal history and no background
that was no more or less
like we normally saw
with the quote normal
criminals coming in.
The common thread for these
folks coming in with DUIs,
reckless driving, assaults, domestic
violence cases was military service.
And we -- I noticed that
they were all veterans.
At that time I was running
a domestic violence court
and I researched and I checked out
and I found Judge Robert Russel
and -- an incredible man.
And, for the most part, we
modeled everything we did
after him in Spokane County.
With that we put together
a veteran's court.
Um, and after the first year, we're
getting ready to go to graduation.
We're going to graduation
with our first guy.
We're very, very excited.
Our first guy, I won't give you his
last name, but he had served four --
two tours with the
ranger battalion in Iraq.
And then he did two National
Guard tours over the course
of this period with
the 1-61 infantry.
And he was a psychology
student at WSU.
Spokane Washington's about 60 north.
His beloved girlfriend in Spokane
called him up one day and said,
"Hey, I think we're
going to break up,"
and did what any good Ranger
Battalion guy would have done
at that time, probably drink
about a half a fifth of whiskey,
hopped in his car, drove
all the way to Spokane.
And as he was professing his
love gently rapping on the door
to his girlfriend who was at 9-1-1,
two law enforcement officers came
up behind him and he turned
a perfectly good misdemeanor
into three felonies.
He had two assaults on an officer.
He had the breaking and
entering into the apartment.
And when they brought us before
him that year earlier, that time,
they reduced the felonies
to misdemeanors,
carried them for dismissal
if he completed this program.
And he did complete the program.
As a matter of fact, he requested
to get out early by about two weeks
because he had to go
on his 5th deployment.
And he definitely had PTSD, but at
that time he just went ahead anyway.
We graduated him early.
About that time my phone rang.
I had a friend of mine in DC
who said, "Hey, you're retired.
You're 58.
How would you like to go
to Afghanistan for a year?"
And I said, "I'd like
to go to Costa Rica.
I'd like to go to Hawaii," but I had
a Special Forces MOS and it would be
as a combat advisor
to an Afghan unit.
And I -- I said, "I got a year.
I can give you a year."
And I gave them a year.
I learned more in that
year about PTSD
and the young people fighting
this war, it was incredible to me.
The best experience I had
over there was working
with these young infantry troops,
32 man platoon supporting us,
average age of about 26, all
National Guardsman with an average
of about two years of combat tours.
That's how they made their living.
Oddly enough and coincidentally,
when I got assigned
to the advisory unit, one of
the individuals was the guy
that first graduated from our class.
And I'm proud to say he
was my guardian angel
for the last two months
in Afghanistan.
With that, our program's
graduated 140 people.
The most important statistic we
have, however, everyone's required
to read a letter to the court at
the end of their, uh, graduation.
Twenty of them indicated
on the record they would
have committed suicide
but for this program.
So it's been an incredible
event for me,
an incredible honor
to be with this panel.
And I'm being sandwiched
between these two Vietnam
vets, I feel somewhat small.
>> Tom Berger: Thank you, Judge.
Um, I'm Tom Berger.
Um --
>> Dr. Tom Berger.
>> Tom Berger: I am the, uh,
son of two World War II vets.
My father was with Carlson's
Raiders, a Marine battalion,
who was wounded on Tarawa.
And by the time he got to the
states, the Marines, at that time,
sent their wounded in the
Pacific to Balboa Hospital
where he met this red-headed nurse.
And so here I am.
[ Laughter ]
In any case, I grew up in a family
that was very attuned
to military service.
Not only my parents, my grandparents
on both sides served in World War I.
In fact, my paternal grandfather was
a tanker in World War I with Patton
and I grew up with a picture of
him standing outside this vehicle
that looked like the
Millennium Falcon.
All right?
That probably ran three
miles and then it broke down.
But, anyway.
So in 1965 I got a letter
from the Army that said,
"We request your presence."
So not knowing what to
do, I called my dad.
And I said, "Pop, what do I do?"
He said, "I don't want
you in the Army."
Um, and um -- "I don't want you in
the Marines because they're already
over there and they're
getting their ass kicked."
Um -- so he said, "Why
don't you try the Navy?"
So I, uh, found out where the local
-- the nearest Navy recruiter was
and ran over there and joined.
And just after I'd raised my hand,
I ran into a high school
classmate in his uniform.
He really looked sharp.
He said, "Tom," he said, "Are
you still going to school?"
I said, "Yeah.
But I'm not taking enough hours
so I got drafted and here I am."
He said, "What was your major?"
I said, "Premed."
He said, "Well, you ought to
sign up to be a corpsman."
He said, "I just did two years
at Memphis Naval Air Station.
There was women.
Skills I learned.
I had to wear a uniform,
but it was cool."
So I ran right in and signed
up to go to corpsman school
and whenever -- when I got home,
I thought my father was going
to beat the crap out of me.
He said, "You know
what corpsman do?"
I said, "No, pop."
He said, "They serve
with the Marines."
So, um, I served with the
Marines in Vietnam off and on,
3rd Mar Division, 3rd
Battalion, 3rd Recon.
Um, got the magic wound in the
spring of 1968 at Khe Sanh.
Um, when I came home
the country was nuts.
I tried to be an EMT or
what they call EMTs now,
but there was no coordination
amongst police, fire,
or emergency medical people.
So we, um, went into a situation.
I went to Roxbury.
I was in Roxbury, Massachusetts.
I went back to Boston for the love
of a woman, which didn't work out.
Um, and got called down
to the projects for, um,
gunshot wound on the 7th floor.
Well, the elevators weren't working
and we had to, uh, take a door off
and put this -- large person
on the door and take her
down seven floors while
people were shooting.
And I thought, "You just came
back from two years of this stuff.
You didn't know why you were there.
Now you're here in the
country of origin, OK,
and you don't know
what's going on here."
So I fooled around a little bit
with anti-war groups, VVAW, uh, SDS,
couple of other groups, and
decided the only way I could deal
with things was to throw myself
into school, which I did.
Um, that's how I dealt
with my stuff.
Um, participating in what we called
rap groups, we met in the libraries,
meeting rooms, we met in churches --
church basements, at bars in
the back rooms where we talked
about our common experiences
because there were no
vet centers at the time.
And, in fact, the current vet
center system as we know it came
out of vets rap groups
started by Vietnam vets.
In any case -- so I went -- I just
went threw myself into school and,
um, got to the point I've got
more degrees than a thermometer.
The point being that's how I
dealt with it and got interested
in veterans issues as I thought
of them via my academic work.
My last academic position,
I ran a little, um, center,
a research center, and we studied
high risk behaviors including
suicide and violence.
Um, so that's how I
got from there to here.
I think the courts are a
phenomenal -- phenomenal happening.
And the word needs to be spread.
I -- as some of my colleagues have
already said via their experience,
um, it's incredible.
One -- one story and then I'll
-- I'll shorten things up here.
Uh, as part of them, um, white
book procedures, I spent some time
out on the west coast in a veterans
court out there in Santa Ana,
and so Santa Ana where
the courts located,
it's not in a very
nice neighborhood.
In fact, when I got there
and stuff they wanted know
if I wanted an escort, um,
because I'd come in at like 7:30
in the morning and
not leave until 7:30
in the evening doing my
interviews and stuff.
But the most impressive things about
it was that a new judge had taken
over in the vet court there, uh,
and he was trying to fill the shoes
of someone who had big
shoes to fill in the vet --
vet court treatment business.
Um, and so when I walked
into his chambers,
here were all these books written by
veterans about veterans et cetera.
I thought, "Hey, that's pretty cool.
He's trying to learn.
He's not a veteran."
But he had surrounded himself
with veterans as part of the --
of the veteran treatment
court in Santa Ana.
And then the most amazing
thing happened.
They were talking about the docket.
People on the docket for the day.
And the judge looked at
me and he said, "Doc,
would you mind staying around.
I think maybe we'd like
your professional opinion."
Now, I have some degrees
in mental health.
So I said, "Sure."
So I did. Now this was a very,
very, very, very serious case.
We are talking pyromania here.
Not only the individual,
but anything around him.
OK? So the person really
needed help.
So the discussion focused on how
can we best help this person,
help this person who has this
really serious problem caused
by his military service.
He had TBI among -- very
serious TBI amongst other things.
And I think, in my --
in my humble opinion,
they did the best thing they
could and that is they put him
in a supervised condition,
conditions --
living conditions --
where he was monitored.
Because if he would have
been on the outside --
he did want to live with his sister.
But if he'd lived with his sister,
he'd've burned her house down
and perhaps killed her
and her family as well.
And I thought, "Wow.
Wow." but it was thoroughly
discussed
by all the members of the court.
There was no acrimony involved,
"Well this guy did this.
He's burned down houses
and this kind of thing and,
you know, we need to lock him up."
It was amazing -- an amazing,
um, event for me to --
so I think the vet courts, as I
said earlier a few minutes ago,
are the best thing that's happened
and I really appreciate, um --
what some folks are doing now
is looking at when folks get
out of the system and how we
get them back, um, into life.
Because prison is a different life.
Uh, but, in any case, it's the best
thing that's happened to veterans,
um, since the VA was started
and we all know about the VA.
But in any case, I'll turn it
over to this marine over here.
>> Jonathan Elias: Bernie, thanks.
Timothy Wynn is a veteran's
treatment court graduate.
Welcome.
>> Timothy Wynn: Thank you.
Thanks, Doc.
My name's Timothy Wynn.
I'm from Philadelphia.
I served in the greatest
fighting force known to mankind,
the United States Marine Corps.
Um, I'm a little biased
I guess, right?
>> Bernie Edelman: It's all right.
>> Jonathan Elias: So all the Navy,
Army, Coasties, everybody else,
Army, they're just -- they're
just going to take that.
Right?
>> Timothy Wynn: Yeah.
Oorah. So -- no, but I, uh
-- I haven't written a book,
but after today, I think
I may be looking to do
that because I do have a story to
tell and I'm lucky enough to kind
of go around and tell my story.
Um, I graduated from the
Philadelphia Veterans Court
and now I am the mentor coordinator
in the same court that
I graduated from.
I stick around there because
there's always a younger version
of me coming through
the door every week.
So I try to help them.
I like to call it borrowed hope.
I remember walking through the
door and not having any hope.
And, um, you know,
people lend it to me.
So I'm there to lend hope to the
veterans that are coming through.
Um, I had seven arrests
before I ended
up in the Philadelphia
Veterans Court.
When I got into the
Philadelphia Veterans Court,
that was my last arrest.
I haven't been arrested since.
I'm working on seven
years clean and sober.
Um, it has absolutely changed
my life around to say the least.
Um, I was housed in the
Philadelphia County Jail for a year
of my life during, um,
several years of arrests
and addiction and everything else.
And, um, I am now in
that prison on Mondays
and Fridays facilitating
trauma groups with the inmates
who are locked up in
that same prison.
Um, when I was in that
prison, there was nobody there.
I was kind of by myself.
Society really wasn't ready for
the veterans that were coming back
from Iraq and Afghanistan.
So it was a lonely time in my life.
So I just make sure that I'm there
every week for those veterans
that are behind a wall today.
Um, and it's been a
rewarding process.
Um, I just try to continue
to do this every single day
and I'm lucky to be here.
I'm lucky that I have
friends at Justice for Vets.
That organization, I can't
say enough about them,
what they do in this country
for veterans every single day.
It's absolutely amazing.
So, um, that's all I got.
>> Jonathan Elias: All right.
Good to have all of you here.
So it's important to point out, too,
if you're just new to the term PTSD
or perhaps you don't really
understand how it works,
if you have a common cold,
the symptoms are easy.
You got fevers.
You got chills.
You stay in bed.
You're weak.
PTSD isn't so simple.
It doesn't have any kind of symptoms
that you necessarily can point to.
In one individual it could be
severe, it could be chronic,
it could be debilitating
to the point
where they can't get out of bed.
And in another, he'll
be fully functioning
or she'll be fully functioning,
but just in an instant
something happens.
So you can't have a blanket
approach to treat PTSD.
I'm sure all of you on stage
would agree with that as well.
Judge, I wanted to
start with you, though.
You talked about it a little
bit in your introduction.
In most of the cases, what
percentage would you attach?
For the folks that come before
your bench who are veterans,
how many would you suspect would
not be before you had they not
experienced what they
did in service?
>> Vance Peterson: I'd
say as much as 80%.
Again, these folks, the
patterns that we normally see,
there's a progression after
somebody passes out of juvenile,
goes into a young adulthood.
And you can see a certain number
of criminal events that may occur.
And they may be light weight things.
It could be just a driving
while license suspended.
It could be a series of speeding
tickets or reckless driving,
maybe a minor assault of some kind.
But the pattern that we saw,
it wasn't like that at all.
The instances generally occurred
after their tours of duty.
And so I would easily
say it's probably 80%
of them wouldn't have been in front
of us but for whatever happened
to them during their deployments.
>> Jonathon Elias: And
the courts or corrections,
they always had one fit --
one size fits all approach
to dealing with veterans.
That's changed, though?
>> Vance Peterson: That's
changed substantially.
We've developed a number
of therapeutic courts.
I was surprised to hear there's
3,000 some, um, mental --
excuse me -- drug courts
in the nation today.
I know there's 330 veterans' courts.
And my push is that we should
probably have 3,000 veterans' courts
because that's about
what we're going to need.
The change, it's substantial.
The veterans are given, I don't
want to say preferential treatment
because often times the probationary
requirements we put them
on the veterans court is greater
than what they're going to have
to do if they just went to what I
call, or what we call, alpha courts,
the straight criminal courts.
Um, each individual defendant that
comes before us we normally spend
about three times as much time
on each individual
defendant just engaging them
because that's important
to the process.
But the idea throughout the staff
with the mentors that we have,
with the mentor coordinator, the
-- the probation department folks,
the idea is to get them
through the program,
the make them succeed,
to -- to salvage them.
We initially started it, we called
it a human salvage operation.
Unlike the traditional alpha
courts where it's more process.
You might have three
cases set for trial.
They're all going to settle.
Everybody has an agreement in terms
of recommendation of the sentence.
And you're done in about two minutes
and you got two minutes
more for the next one.
Well, you spend a lot more time with
the veterans and it's important.
>> Jonathon Elias: And by the
time they get to you, Greg,
some would argue maybe
it's too late.
When they end up in the correction
system, but that's not the case.
And a lot of times when
you're dealing with PTSD --
and as we just pointed
out -- it's --
it's an individual by
individual case basis.
Is there a switch inside every
single one of these people
that at some point you can get to or
hopefully get to, flick the switch
and things will at least be maybe
put them on a more productive plan?
>> Greg Crawford: I
think so, Jonathon.
Um, if I could just
come back a second.
When I was a probation
officer just after 9-11,
I started in Pierce County,
which is just up the straight
from Joint Base Lewis-McChord.
We didn't have veteran's treatment
courts and, um, there wasn't a lot
of veteran specific programming
in the justice system.
And so, um, as you can imagine,
after the wars in Afghanistan
and Iraq started and
folks started coming home,
soldiers started coming home,
we started to see a large influx
like you all did of veterans
in our justice system.
And we didn't have
veteran's treatment courts.
And so I was the domestic violence
officer and so they were there
for a domestic violence charge
and that's what we supervised.
We didn't touch the
underlying issues of, um,
PTSD or TBI or anything like that.
>> Jonathon Elias: And that's
the vast majority of the cases
that come back when
you see them enter
into the system as
domestic violence?
>> Greg Crawford: At
least on my workload.
Um, but -- but they
sit before me broken.
Um, you know, essentially
their careers are ruined
or they're either, you know,
a dishonorable or other
than honorable or awaiting
discharge.
Um, families wrecked.
Um, they're just a shell
of their former self.
And so that was before veteran's
treatment courts and now,
since 2008, we -- we've got a
330 with, I would say, you know,
nearly 100 in various stages
of planning and implementation.
They're catching fire
across the country.
And what they're doing is they're --
they're digging deep besides
the charge at hand and Judge --
General Tate talked about
that holistic approach, um,
to -- to treating veterans.
And, um, that -- that works.
Um, and I have -- I have a
colleague -- I won't name --
say his name, but he said
after a couple of months he was
in with denial about, you know,
committing to a veterans
treatment court.
And after a while it just
clicked and he just felt
like he had a sense of purpose back.
Um, so, to me, I think these
veterans treatment courts are
getting at those underlying
issues and, at some point,
especially the value of
the veteran peer mentor,
and kind of helping
walk them -- you know --
walking them through the system
and providing that support,
at some point, they get it.
>> Jonathan Elias: Tim, you'd be the
best one to answer this question too
because you came through
the program.
At what point did that switch go
off for you where you realized,
you know what, that's not
the life I want to lead
and you know the path
where it leads to?
When did the switch go off?
What resource was made
available to you
to enable you to flick that switch?
>> Timothy Wynn: I think the
changing moment for me was
when I was in the mental health
unit in the bowels of the prison.
And, um, they kept giving me
medication and I was just done
with medication at this point.
I had gotten so much
medication from the VA and I --
I'd abused them and I just was
tired of feeling like that.
I felt vulnerable in population
and I didn't want to
take any more pills.
And I was arguing with a lady in the
bowels of the prison who was going
to give me more of these pills.
And the door slowly slid
open and in walks a man
who I had no idea who he was.
Um, and he says to
the lady, he says, um,
"Can I just have a
couple minutes with him?"
And she got up, left, and
he sat down and, you know,
he wasn't a therapist,
he wasn't, you know,
licensed to treat PTSD
or nothing like that.
But what he was a Vietnam veteran.
And that's the first time I was
introduced to peer-to-peer support.
And I'll never forget
what he said to me.
He said, "That person you were
before you left is gone forever.
That person is gone.
He's never coming back.
You're a changed person and you need
to find different ways
to combat this."
And I think the first time I heard
that was the first time I realized
that I had to surrender to win.
See, because surrender
is not in our vocabulary.
You know? But it's a very
hard thing to accept.
And, um, from that
point on I started
to kind of turn my life around.
>> Jonathan Elias: Is there any
part of you before you went off
to combat that's still alive?
Like when you go home and
you see an old friend?
Because I -- I saw that video
and the guy said, you know,
"All my friends had changed,"
and, you know, we're all sitting
in this room as educated
folks and we're saying, "No.
No. No. No.
You changed.
They're all exactly the same."
>> Timothy Wynn: Yeah.
>> Jonathan Elias: That's why they
say you can never go home again
because those who leave are
the ones who evolve or change
or become different and then
they go back expecting everything
to be the same and it's
not because they're not.
>> Timothy Wynn: Yeah.
It's definitely not the same.
I remember coming home and not being
able to really talk to anybody.
Um, you know, I can't talk
to, you know, my mother.
My own mother, I can't talk
to my next-door neighbor.
Um --
>> Jonathan Elias: Because
they just wouldn't understand?
>> Timothy Wynn: Yeah.
And it's not their fault.
You know? They wouldn't
understand because they --
they didn't go through it.
And that's OK.
Um, that's why I think peer-to-peer
support is so important,
um, when it comes to this.
You know how Doc talked about, you
know, sitting in those rap groups.
You know, myself and my friend,
Robert Shipper, who's here today,
you know, we have our own rap
groups every Monday night, um,
in our community with veterans.
So that's the most important thing
to me is peer-to-peer support
>> Jonathan Elias: And
it's interesting too.
You came back from a war where
you have a civilian population
that embraces our veterans.
You know, they have parades.
They don't -- they
get a treatment --
the red carpet treatment,
if you will.
>> Timothy Wynn: Mm-hmm.
>> Jonathan Elias: But, I
mean, let's just face it,
the military does a
lot of things right.
What they're not very good
at is transitioning warriors
from a warrior mentality or ethos
into a civilian based ethos because,
again, that's an impossible --
that's like going from a NASCAR
doing 210 in the fast lane to jump
into a Prius going 20 miles an hour.
It's an impossible transition.
And that -- and, Doc , I
wanted to bring you guys
in because you came back from a very
unpopular war where you either had
to bury the fact that you
served or at least kind
of protect the fact of what you did.
>> Tom Berger: Right.
The story, I came back, uh, I was
in, um, St. Louis airport and I'm --
I'm honored as a Navy corpsman.
I wear the Marine -- I can
wear the Marine green uniform.
OK? There's a special
band on the sleeve
that distinguishes me as a corpsman.
So I had my medals on and stuff, or
ribbons on, and walked up to the bar
in the airport and ordered a drink.
Uh, had a few anyway
on the airplane.
Uh, in any case, there was a guy
at the bar looks at my uniform
and he said, "How many
babies did you kill?"
And before I could hit him
with the beer bottle, OK?
The bartender grabbed this guy
and threw him out of the bar.
That's my first experience
coming back.
Now the guy was probably sloshed
and -- and the whole business,
but that was my reaction.
All right?
And then not being able
to go places in uniform
because people would really --
let's just say really rude to you.
OK? With language we didn't
even use in the Corps.
OK? Um, but Tim's exactly right.
When you come back,
it's so different.
It's so different.
And nobody knows how to
deal with you because of it.
I appreciate -- I appreciate
what the country --
how it values it's veterans,
but they need to understand
war changes people.
It changes people.
And so it's not just, "Thank
you for your service."
It's, "Welcome home."
And there's a big difference
between those two phrases.
>> Jonathan Elias: Your experience?
>> Bernie Edelman: Well, two years
ago I went to the first reunion
of my college fraternity
of more than 30 years.
There were about 50 of us in this
really nice Italian restaurant
in New York City, in Manhattan.
Uh, and these are good guys,
guys I was friends with.
They're lawyers.
They're doctors, dentists,
college professors.
And of the 50 there were four of
us who served in some capacity
or other in the military.
One, a lawyer friend of mine,
was in the National Guard.
Another guy, he was
an 11 Bravo, a grunt,
but they didn't send him to Vietnam.
They sent him to Germany.
Third guy did not want to get
drafted so he thought he was smart.
He joined the Air Force
and wound up in Thailand
where he lost his best friend
and lost a lot of other guys.
And it -- there was, to me,
a kind of barrier, in a way,
between me and these other fellows.
Good guys.
You know? Successful guys.
The people I'm most
comfortable around are veterans.
Uh, and I know when I came home --
it's something that you didn't
necessarily talk about, but I was --
like Doc -- I was a little bit
angry at what had been going on.
I was there in 1970.
We were doing the so-called
phased withdrawal.
I couldn't see logically why
American troops were still going
out on combat missions and dying.
Um, so I protested the war.
Came down here in the big
anti-war demonstration called Dewey
Canyon III.
And it was the first time since
the bonus marches in 1932,
I believe it was, who came to
Washington to say, "Look at us.
Get out of Vietnam, uh, now."
Um, and I think it had an effect.
I certainly hope it had an effect.
But there was certainly
in me and I know in a lot
of other folks the sense of
alienation, uh, in coming home.
And I was not a combatant.
Uh, when I was there, I
had top secret clearance.
I could travel around.
I spent a lot of time with
the 91st Evacuation Hospital
up in a place called Chu Lai,
uh, with the docs and the nurses.
Saw as much as of the, uh,
debasement and the debris of war as,
you know, most grunts did.
And, you know -- and, as
Doc said, it changes you
and unless you're there, you
really can't understand even
if you watch the best war
movies that were ever made.
>> Jonathan Elias: Let's talk about,
for a second, identifying some
of the telltale signs of PTSD.
It's always helpful if you're
going to try and tackle a problem
to at least understand the
problem you're up against.
From my understand, from my
experience from talking to veterans,
alcohol, drug use, those
are about as common
across the board telltale
signs you're going to have
because of either withdrawal
or escapism.
Um, maybe not being
able to socialize.
They'll be in a social setting
that, back when they were perhaps
in their home town maybe
with some high school buddies
and they just start yacking
about a football game,
they feel out of place,
they don't contribute.
Give me some other strong telltale
songs for anybody perhaps watching
or anybody in the audience
that maybe they have a loved
one that's going through this
and they want to make
sure that they can
at least identify what
it is they're up against?
>> Tom Berger: Hyperarousal
certainly is one of
and I'll bet every combat vet
in this room knows exactly
what I'm talking about.
It happened to me this morning.
A colleague -- now I place
my desk so it faces the door.
Now most, you know, um, office
management things says, "Well,
that's kind of -- put it
to the side or whatever."
I can't do that because even
with my desk facing the doorway,
if I'm focused on reading something
or whatever and somebody just says,
"Hi, Doc," it scares the
you know what out of me.
And that can happen anywhere.
If I'm focused on something
and people call my name
or I hear a loud noise,
something like that,
that's certainly a problem.
The other thing has been mentioned
earlier in the conversation, uh,
nightmares and flashbacks.
And those are two different things.
OK, you have nightmares
when you sleep at night.
And they may be the same nightmare.
Flashbacks happen any time and you
are back there because trauma is --
and particularly severe trauma --
can change the circuitry of
the brain so that certain --
want to call them, uh -- uh --
triggers, will put you right back
where a particular
traumatic event occurred.
So those are a couple of other --
>> Jonathan Elias: Does --
let me ask you this too.
It's 42 years since
the end of the war.
Have -- has in subsided?
Has it gotten easier?
Has it -- has it kind of freed
you a little bit, or is it right
at the forefront as
it's always been?
>> Tom Berger: Um,
there are a couple of --
I don't want to go back to
Vietnam despite all the, uh,
overtures in friendship and
Vietnam Veterans of America,
where I work, has led the way.
We have, um, a veteran's
initiative, which we can talk
about another time another place.
Uh, I don't want to go back
there because I am afraid
that it will bring back stuff
that I've had to deal with, uh,
through therapy and
through rap groups and stuff
and I don't want through that again.
But I do have a couple of recurring
nightmares that I can't seem
to get rid of and they were
pretty traumatic situations.
So -- but they come
back and it's usually
when I'm -- I'm stressed out.
OK?
>> Jonathan Elias: Tim?
>> Timothy Wynn: I think anger is,
uh, a main one speaking for myself.
>> Jonathan Elias:
You explode quickly?
>> Timothy Wynn: Absolutely.
You know, I've obviously found ways
to, uh, you know, combat that, um,
you know, through group
therapy and stuff like that.
>> Jonathan Elias: Now
let me ask you this.
The loved ones around you before
they knew what they were up against,
were they just saying, "You know
what, he's got a hairpin trigger.
That's just how he's always been?"
They try and rationalize away the
behavior not to try to cope with it?
>> Timothy Wynn: Yeah.
I mean, they didn't really
understand it, like I said earlier.
They just kind of thought,
like, uh, you know --
they knew something
was wrong, but, again,
they didn't know what was wrong.
They didn't know what
they were looking at.
they were facing.
And, you know, anger, I think
it stems from, you know,
when you come back you have these
-- this sort of -- like I --
I call it like your standing
in the shallows of the ocean
and that wave just
keeps hitting you.
And it's a wave of these
emotions that keeps coming.
You you've never felt this
stuff before so you get angry.
You get angry because you can't
navigate through your day.
You can't be that social person.
You can't go hang out with the guys
and talk about the football game.
You know? You would rather isolate
-- at least this is what I did.
I isolated.
I used drugs and alcohol because
they're 100% effective every time.
They numb all those emotions.
>> Jonathan Elias:
You know, we've --
as a nation, we've been at it
for 240 years and we've been
at war a lot of that time.
And, you know, all throughout the
generations from the Civil War
to World War II, they would call it
shell shock or they just call it,
"Oh, he's being quiet," whatever.
I mean, now we call it PTSD because
we've identified it as a problem.
But this is a problem that has
plagued our returning warriors
since we've been at
it in the battlefield.
And, you know, Judge, I'm just
curious, some of the things
that you have seen, because
I'm sure you had a lot
of cases come before you
where you have telltale signs
that run from A to Z on this one.
>> Greg Crawford: All -- all of the
substance abuse issues are there,
of course, and a lot of times
that's just a reaction to the anger.
I think that the -- really
the underlying current
that affects the most is
-- is just plain anger.
You know, I remember as we're
getting ready to climb on a C-17
to leave Afghanistan after that time
some of the younger folks, again,
these young 11-B infantry
troopers, you know, "Gosh, we --
we went to Afghanistan and the rest
of the country went to Walmart."
It's almost a resentment
that -- that --
that when you get back you kind of
resent the fact that you get there.
And, of course, on the return of
the Iraq and the Afghan guys that --
it's much different
from the Vietnam era.
You -- you hear, you know,
"Thank you for your service," um,
an awful lot and I have to admit,
yeah, I was angry when I got back.
I -- the Army was still pretty bad
about how they handled
you when you came back.
>> Jonathan Elias: But -- let me ask
you -- all of you -- do you think --
because the military spends
gazillions of dollars on everything
from perfecting the ways
of killing people to trying
to understand the warriors
to artificial intelligence.
I'm just curious, is there
any kind of mechanism
that anyone could provide
to ready them
for what they're really
going to experience?
I know they train them for combat,
but training somebody for combat
and experiencing and living through
combat, totally different things.
>> Tom Berger: Well, one of
the things is -- and it's --
it's spot on what you just said.
They train you for
situations that threaten you,
that put you in a sense
of danger and you react.
And if you follow that training,
chances are you're going
to make it through that situation.
When you come home, OK, you have to
go back to the old way of thinking,
which is just because
Fido pooped on the floor,
that is not a life
threatening situation.
But, OK, you react that way.
And is one of the things they should
consider, in my humble opinion,
and Canada did it for a while
and the UK did it for a while,
is they put their troops in
sort of a -- a decompression.
I believe it was the UK --
or was it the Canadians --
had a place on Cypress.
OK? And some cases there were,
you know, married couples
and stuff could -- and they
helped them decompress, um,
as sort of like a post-service
boot camp.
Now whether that would get a lot of
support down the street, um, or not,
you know, that's -- that's
neither here nor there.
But we could do something better
on the end of it to get us back
in terms of the transition system.
>> Jonathan Elias: Please.
>> Greg Crawford: So, you know, I
work for [inaudible] and my job is
to really identify gaps, you
know, and throughout the continuum
of criminal justice to improve
outcomes for veterans and one
of the interviews I was conducting,
uh, with a veteran, um --
you know, he said, "They trained me,
you know, to go to basic training.
They trained me to
go to my first duty.
They trained me to go to combat, but
they didn't train me to come home."
And I think that that's
a real gap in our system.
I always, um -- couple
-- couple points.
One, um, we need to reduce the
stigma for soldiers to ask for help.
We need to do a better
job of helping them.
And I think that why does the
first opportunity to intervene
in their life have to be
the criminal justice system?
I think that if we can do, uh --
I think there's specific funding
with DOD to, um, you know, to
train people, to pay for uniforms,
to, um, you know, travel.
But there's no specific
funding to come home
and to help them acclimate home.
And I think that that's a real
gap, um, that we need to address.
>> Jonathan Elias: Let
me just -- go ahead.
>> Tom Berger: And I think
there's a real problem also.
The military has changed, although,
it's still defect in a lot of ways
like it was in World War II.
I say this because I've
done some clinical work
with Delta Force people
and -- and SEALs.
Some said it earlier.
Most Americans don't appreciate
the tempo of operations,
um, over in the big sandbox.
It's -- I mean, heavy duty intense.
The general -- the general and, uh,
my colleague sitting next to me,
the judge, will tell
you what it's like.
But the fact of the matter
is that these folks are
under such intense --
particularly in our --
in our special ops groups --
are under such intense pressure that
life back here is not very realistic
to them when they come home.
They try and adjust.
OK? But why do so many of
our special ops people feel
that they're more at
home back there?
>> Jonathan Elias: Let me
ask this question, too,
because I know we live in an ADD
society and I don't mean to use
that term pejoratively, but I think
it's true that you walk around today
and you'll see nine out of 10 people
walking around with their phones.
They're connected to
I don't know what.
I mean, maybe there's a
text they can't go without
or a headline they can't go
without, but folks who are warriors
who have been in combat -- and
I've heard this probably 99%
of the time -- for
them time stands still.
Time slows down.
The continuum just absolutely
comes to a grinding halt.
And when they come home they feel
as though the world is running
by them 1,000 miles an hour
and they're stuck in a spot
where they just need
somebody to talk to.
So now let's get into the resources
because we have the veterans court,
which is a system that
has started to spread,
but certainly could grow a lot more.
But what are the resources available
to people especially with PTSD
and TBIs coming home that
they could reach out to
that would help their experience?
Because we have folks that,
you know, are watching on TV
and perhaps they're sitting there
saying, "I didn't get out of bed
until 11 O'clock this morning.
I don't know why I'd
want to get out of bed."
What resource can they reach out to?
Because there's a lot of them.
>> Tom Berger: There are a lot.
Um, lots of good community.
I would, uh, say for those --
and we know that because of
all the media surrounding a lot
of the problems with the VA,
they don't trust the VA
hospitals for whatever reason.
The Vet Centers.
Try the Vet Centers!
Because they are the most cost
efficient mental health operation
in the VA system.
>> Jonathan Elias: And they -- and
all they have to do is just walk in
and say, "I just need
someone to talk to."
They don't have to
fill out the paperwork
and go through the red tape.
>> Tom Berger: Right.
Your mental health information
that you choose to share
at a Vet Center doesn't go
to the mothership unless
you sign a consent.
OK? And, for those vet centers
that have the resources,
meaning the money and the people,
they also can work with families.
And that's a big deal
because the big hospitals
and stuff aren't allowed to do that.
There are some programs and
kinds of -- but the vet centers,
I highly recommend the vet centers.
And a lot of the team leaders,
what they call the director
at vet centers, are
combat veterans themselves.
And that's what made it such
a success that 10 years ago,
15 years ago I guess now because
we've been in this latest morass
for that long, most of the
team leaders were combat
Vietnam veterans.
>> Jonathan Elias: Bernie?
>> Bernie Edelman: There are 330 or
so VTCs, veteran's treatment courts.
There are exactly 300 Vet
Centers, but they're located mostly
in cities, uh, in strip malls, uh --
there should be twice
that number at least.
That's where resources need to go.
Uh, but it's also -- we depend upon
the VA to -- and the government --
to help those who are
several combat wounded, uh,
to help them fiscally,
physically, mentally.
Spiritually, you have to depend
on the community that you live in.
And a lot of Americans
prefer not to deal with that.
Stop and think about this.
In the Second World War when the
population of this country was
about 130,000,000 or so,
16,000,000 Americans,
men and women, were in uniform.
Just about everyone in the
country was somehow involved
in the war effort.
I don't know what the
numbers were for Korea.
In Vietnam it had shrunk
to something
like 9%, some people said 4%.
Right now less than 1/5
of 1% of Americans --
now we're not talking about
5 year old children --
but of Americans I guess 18 or
above serve in the military.
This is a tiny number.
People go through college.
They don't have to worry about
being drafted or anything.
When we were in school, that
was, you know, one of the things
that kept us in school as
long as we had the grades.
But people come home and a lot
of times there's something
missing in community.
Uh, which is tragic and it
leads to more [inaudible].
People aren't welcomed home into
the bosom of a grateful nation
because too often the nation is
not grateful for a war without end.
And that's what we had in Vietnam.
That's what we have now.
>> Jonathan Elias: Is it a --
>> Melissa Fitzgerald:
There's a veterans crisis line
if you wouldn't mind
giving out that number.
>> Jonathan Elias: Sure.
Um, the Veterans Crisis Line is
another resource you can turn to.
It's 1-800-273-8255.
And then when you call that
number you can just press 1.
>> Tom Berger: Press 1.
>> Jonathan Elias:
Tim, let me go to you
because you came back from this war.
And you had said -- "Hope"
was the word you used.
Um, the veterans that I talked
to coming back from this war,
they seemed to think that the people
at home, while they're grateful
for their service, they don't
understand what their service
was for.
And then the translation to you is
then, "What the hell was I doing?"
Is that a part of what you
processed or are still processing?
>> Timothy Wynn: I think for a short
period of time I went through that.
Not so much now.
Um, to me, what I did over there
was standing shoulder-to-shoulder
with my brothers and
sisters in arms.
You know, we -- we did
what we had to do to get
through every single day
to protect one another.
And, you know, I don't get to
far into it as far as, you know,
political why we did what we did.
Um, that's not my concern.
My concern then was protecting the
people to the right and the left
of me and that still stands today.
That's what I do here
in my community.
>> Jonathan Elias: Did you have
a clearly defined objective
as a warrior in battle?
Did you understand day-to-day
what it is you were trying
to do or accomplish?
>> Timothy Wynn: Yes.
You know, I, uh -- I had --
I was a sergeant and my job was to
protect the people underneath me.
And that was my main
objective every single day.
Um, I ran convoys over there.
I was a 50 Cal gunner
on top of a Humvee.
My objective was to get the
people in that convoy from point A
to point B -- point A to point
B. That was my projective.
Um, there are also good
people in the country
of Iraq who need protection.
And we protected them as well.
>> Bernie Edelman: Bob Birdnow
[assumed spelling] is here
in the audience.
Bob comes from Quincy,
Massachusetts.
Um, for the past several
years he and I, his wife,
couple of other folks, have gone
up to Quincy at the end of April
for a ceremony, United
Combat Veterans of Quincy,
95% of whom served
in the Marine Corps.
Talk about brotherhood.
There you have it.
Uh, it used to be a handful of guys
would go down to this clock tower,
uh, which had the names inscribed
on it of 45 of Quincy's --
the sons of Quincy who died
during the Vietnam War.
They'd read the names
and then they would go
to this fairly awful
Chinese restaurant, uh,
but there was a certain
loyalty there.
When they added Bob's brother's name
to the -- the roster of the dead,
uh, things I think
started to change.
You had a situation where more
and more people started, uh --
resident -- a son of Quincy, rather
-- came to give you keynote speech.
Here you have a situation where the
community embraces those who served
and tries to help them heal.
It's a small part of the community,
but it's always, it seems,
veterans helping veterans.
Those who didn't serve, you
don't get it the same way.
A lot of veterans -- a lot
of non-veterans will
say, "Welcome home."
That's nice.
"Thank you for your service."
But they don't understand it.
When a veteran says that to
someone who's come back, it has --
it's a different context almost.
And in Quincy, it's an
example of what I think a lot
of other communities can
do and should do not only
for the younger guys,
but for all veterans.
You know, a lot of the
veteran's treatment courts,
there are more Vietnam era
veterans than there are Iraq
and Afghanistan veterans.
>> Jonathan Elias: Right.
>> Bernie Edelman: When
you were mentioning, uh --
uh, or in the film clip we saw, 22
veterans commit suicide every day.
>> Tom Berger: Twenty.
>> Bernie Edelman: It said 22 there.
But --
>> Jonathan Elias: Even
one a day is too much.
>> Tom Berger: Correct!
>> Bernie Edelman: Something like
70% of those veterans are age 55 --
>> Tom Berger: And older.
>> Bernie Edelman: Or older.
They're not the young
people who came back.
The connotation was, "Here,
look at these damaged people
who've -- who are coming home."
A lot of the people
who are among that --
>> Jonathan Elias: Well, one
of the largest homeless
populations right now in our country
of veterans is the Vietnam War.
>> Bernie Edelman: Oh, yeah.
>> Tom Berger: And -- and --
excuse me -- I would argue --
here's a discussion point,
OK, because not all of you are
in the audience and are veterans.
What Bernie said about the
veterans in the community is fine --
to draw veterans together.
What I would say is instead
of having veterans night
at the ballpark, take the
resources that are used to do that,
make sure that your community mental
health office is not only open 24/7
several days a week, but
is staffed with somebody
that can handle military
PTSD , or MST .
That is something that the community
can do to help our veterans.
>> Jonathan Elias: Greg,
let me ask you this.
Especially now we're talking about
resources that may be tightening up.
Budgets may be changing and
there may not be as much money
to help fund some of the
programs that are currently there.
What can people do?
And I especially want to
deal with folks in rural --
I'm from a small town
outside of California.
I know in those communities a lot
of our population ended up going
in enlisting into the militaries.
So what do folks in
rural communities do?
How do they deal with returning
warriors who are having these issues
who become somewhat isolated,
who perhaps maybe turn
to drugs or alcohol as an escape?
What do you do for them?
>> Greg Crawford: Well, I think, um,
number one, the National Institute
of Corrections provides training
and technical assistance.
So if your jurisdictional
out there is looking
to implement a veterans
treatment court program, um,
they can contact NIC, uh,
at NICIC.gov and, you know,
give us a call and we can talk about
what your issues are and whether
or not you want to start
a veterans treatment court
or some other specific programming
either in a jail or a prison.
Um -- or they can contact
Justice for Vets, uh,
or there's grants available, um,
through the Federal Government.
Um, but what I would say is you
have to understand your population.
And I think data drives
a lot of decisions
in our jurisdictions
across the country.
So if you can figure out how many
veterans you have in your jail
or on your probation caseloads,
I think that that could help lead
to -- you know -- warranting a
program in your jurisdiction.
Then don't just ask,
"Are you a veteran?"
because sometimes they
think you are only a veteran
if you serve in combat.
You have to say, "Have you
served in the military?"
That's the key question to ask.
And so once you've justified your
programming, a lot of times --
and Judge Peterson, I think
you can speak to this --
you can create something
with the exciting resources.
Um, I don't know if you want to --
>> Jonathan Elias: Yeah.
I -- I -- I'm dying to know like
right now if we had 5,000 judges
from across the country that are
just sitting here watching this,
what would you tell them about how
things should at least be modified
in order to deal with the growing
population of returning vets
who may be dealing with
some of these issues?
>> Vance Peterson: Well,
I'd tell them first,
"You're going to prosecute
these guys anyway.
You're -- you're going
to prosecute them.
You're going to defend them.
They're going to be charged.
They're going to have a
probation officer involved.
You're going to have a court
-- court clerk pull the file.
Why don't you put them
all on the same docket?
It doesn't cost you
any more to do that.
And, from that, then you can
develop a veteran's court docket.
And then you can start
looking into local resources."
At one point in time I
remember talking to Judge Russel
and there was a -- a concern
about making cookie cutter courts,
all the veterans courts
would look alike.
The reality was that every
jurisdiction is different.
Everybody has a different
group of veterans.
In Lewiston, Idaho,
90% of their veterans
in veteran's courts are marines.
In our jurisdiction
it's about 60% Army,
although we have an Air Force base.
Some courts will handle
felony level events.
Some courts will only
handle misdemeanor events.
Some folks do a combination.
But you can do this -- you can put
these programs together and set
up a docket and it
doesn't cost you anything.
>> Jonathan Elias: You're talking
about making resources available
so that they're going to be charged
with their crime and they're going
through the judicial system,
but, at the same time,
you're going to have
a peer one-on-one
with a vet talking to these folks?
>> Vance Peterson: And each one of
the courts has a mentor type system.
Each one of the courts has
developed their own particularized
mentor system.
We developed a forum and the
forum meets once a month.
Every veteran is basically sentenced
to attend 12 -- or six forums.
They're given 24 months
of probation,
you attend six forums,
it's only 18 months.
You lose a month of probation
every time you attend a forum.
If you attend 12 forums,
you're done.
So the incentive is
to come to the forum.
At the forum we feed them.
We give them a dinner.
Then we have them -- there are set
up a bunch of different resources,
community resources for child
support, department of licensing
for driver's licenses,
landlord tenant attorneys.
We put every resource available
to a veteran in one room.
After they're done going
through the resource portion,
they go through two, one
hour group therapy sessions.
And with that, um, they then get
through the program in 12 months --
>> Jonathan Elias:
And let me stop you.
And a lot of these resources
you're talking about,
in most cases it's a phone
call because they'd be willing
to volunteer their time and service
because of who we're talking about,
the population we're talking about?
>> Vance Peterson: Yes.
>> Jonathan Elias:
Greg, you had something?
>> Greg Crawford: Yeah.
I want to -- I want to say
a couple different things.
Number one, um, you can look
at Veteran Treatment Courts,
A Second Chance for Vets.
There's a lot of information
about how to start a court
or the right questions
to ask your jurisdiction.
Um, but also you can
contact Justice for Vets.
They have four mentor courts.
You can make a request to
actually take a team onsite
and go see what's going on
and -- and view that court.
>> Melissa Fitzgerald: Yeah.
If you're a jurisdiction and you're
interested in any way setting
up a veteran's treatment court,
please go to our website.
There's a tremendous amount of
information at JusticeforVets.org.
>> Jonathan Elias:
Let me -- hold on.
Let me do this real quick.
Tim, when you came back -- the goal
with PTSD is first diagnosis it,
figuring out what you're up against,
and then intervening as quickly
as possible so that you can
intercept that from turning
into really bad decisions and
ultimately trying to determine
if somebody's going to
go out there and act out,
which could be committing crimes.
What would have been in one thing
that could have intercepted you
immediately coming back from combat
that would have helped immensely?
>> Timothy Wynn: A veteran's court.
No doubt.
>> Jonathan Elias:
A veteran's court?
>> Timothy Wynn: No
doubt in my mind.
If I were to land in veteran's
court with my first arrest,
I wouldn't have had seven arrests,
I wouldn't have spent a
year of my life in prison.
I wouldn't have not be
in my daughter's life
for the first four
years of her life.
>> Jonathan Elias: You needed
a vet to look you in the eye
and tell you you're a changed man
and you need to get over that,
you need to figure this out?
>> Timothy Wynn: Absolutely.
And I need a room where
I can walk into
and all the resources
are right there.
A lot of people are perplexed at
veteran's courts, you know, work.
They say, you know, "How
is this even possible
and doesn't it cost a ton of money?"
And in reality it's one day a week.
It's one judge.
It's one courtroom.
It's one staff for one day per week,
but the impact is unbelievable.
>> Jonathan Elias: And
they're speaking your language?
>> Timothy Wynn: They're
speaking my language.
I walk into that room,
I can get everything
that I need all in one room.
And that's something that
you can't get anywhere else.
>> Bernie Edelman: There's
something even before all that.
If somebody commits a
crime, the first people
in the criminal justice
system that they're going
to come across are the police.
On the Justice Involved Veterans
Network, there's one gentleman,
Captain Blair Myhand of
Apex, North Carolina.
>> Jonathan Elias: Now Chief.
>> Bernie Edelman: Now -- OK.
That I didn't know.
And what he does is he takes
a couple of vets who are
on the police force and trains
them in how to deal with a crisis
if somebody is a veteran.
And if they know the person's a
veteran because the spouse tells,
uh, the first officers, these guys
come and they know what to say,
they know how to bring somebody down
from the crisis she's in or he's in.
He also does this training for other
police departments I think twice
a year.
But the police have a greater
role that they can play
and it's not going on as -- nearly
as much as I think it ought to.
>> Jonathan Elias: Is it fair
to say that a barrier right now
that exists is -- especially
with law enforcement,
because I know a lot of my
friends who are police officers
and they tend to give the benefit
of the doubt to a returning vet
if they're caught up in something.
They kind of will pat
them on the back and go,
"Come on, man, don't do this."
Is that doing them a favor
or is that hurting them?
Because you're basically in denial.
You're just saying, "You're a vet,
I'm going to cut you
some slack here."
>> Timothy Wynn: Yeah.
It's -- in my opinion, it's
definitely hurting them.
And I've been cut breaks.
>> Jonathan Elias: It's
just kicking the can.
>> Timothy Wynn: Yeah.
Basically.
Um, but one of the most
important things at my job now is
to do crisis intervention training
with the local police department.
I go up to the Philadelphia
Police Department.
I go over to Camden, New
Jersey, and I tell my story.
And I tell them flat out, you
know, the best thing to happen
to me was getting that final arrest
and not getting let go that day
and actually getting put
in a veteran's court.
It absolutely changed my life.
I educate the police on PTSD, uh,
TBI, you know, domestic violence,
which is very high amongst veterans.
Um, and I tell my story.
And it really strikes home with
them because, at the end of the day,
they're the first responders,
they're the ones out on the streets
that are coming in contact
with these veterans.
The ones that are out there buying
heroin, getting in bar fights,
stuff like that, they're the
ones showing up on the scene
and the decision that they make
that day could absolutely change
their life, um, for the better.
Getting arrested is not the worst
thing that can happen to a vet.
>> Jonathan Elias: Go ahead, Greg.
>> Greg Crawford: It can be kicking
the can down the road, but it --
unless you know, you know,
what -- what you're doing.
You have to understand your
resources in the community
and you have to be
willing to make a referral.
Um, I think some of the things
that we're working on at NIC
and in our partnership
with some of the folks
up here are a couple things.
Real quick is increasing what they
call the responsivity issues have
veterans, looking at developing
training around military culture,
um, issues transitioning from
military to civilian life,
the underlying issues
of PTSD, and TBI.
NIC is working on this curriculum
with the Center for
Court Innovation.
We hope to pilot test this in FY-18
and make this available
to the field.
But in addition to that the National
Institute of Corrections partnered
with the Bureau of Justice
Assistance, um, and the Center
for Court Innovation to develop
the first set of screening tools
that factors in the
complexities of war trauma.
So there's a comprehensive tool
and a case planning protocol
that will help guide veterans
treatment courts on how
to best serve the veterans
in their justice system.
>> Jonathan Elias: OK.
Well, we just have a few
minutes left for the panel.
What I wanted to do was just
get some closing remarks,
if you can keep them brief though,
if we can just go down the line.
And I -- I guess for me, what I
want to kind of hear at the end,
and I'm sure maybe some of the folks
in the audience here too, is --
is there a hopeful
message to pass on?
What is it that you hope will
happen in the years to come as --
and we've already identified
the problem?
Obviously we're a nation
of liking to fix problems.
So what's your hope?
We'll start with you
Tim, from the end.
>> Timothy Wynn: Oh, I hope that
all the work that's been done
up to this point doesn't
go to waste.
I hope people keep the fire lit,
and you know, keep their pedal --
their foot to the pedal and stay on
the gas and keep this thing going
because it's not going to
clear up any time soon.
Um, you know, we have Vietnam vets
who are coming into our courts
who have never dealt with anything
for years and years and years
and they're coming into the court
and they're finally
changing their lives around.
So it's never too late.
This is not just about
Iraq and Afghanistan.
It's about Vietnam vets.
It's about a ton of veterans
out there that are going
through certain things
in their lives.
We need to keep coming
together as a community,
as a nation, um to combat this.
We need to stick together.
We need to educate ourselves.
Everybody needs to be educated
in this area, in -- in --
in veterans' issues,
if we want to succeed.
>> Jonathan Elias: Tom?
>> Tom Berger: Um, I'd
just echo what Tim said.
Keep up the good work.
For those of you who
learned something today,
take it back to your community
and push it as far as you can.
>> Jonathan Elias: Judge?
>> Vance Peterson: One of the
most important therapeutic factors
for any veteran is simply
talking to another veteran.
We'd like to see that happen prior
to their criminal justice
involvement,
but certainly veterans
talking to veterans is one
of the best therapies
available out there.
The communities need
to get involved.
The communities need to
get deeper into the --
into the veterans system and
understand what's going on we them
and do as much preemptive
things as they can possibly do.
And it doesn't really cost an
awful lot of money to do it.
>> Jonathan Elias: Bernie?
>> Bernie Edelman: Next time
our government makes a decision
to send men and women,
mostly young, off to war,
they need to also plan fiscally
for when these folks come back
so that there are programs for them.
That does not go on.
Uh, once you're used up,
too often the military wants
to say, "bye bye," to you.
Uh, and people come back.
They are -- they haven't
re-acclimated.
They are drifting.
And they are hurting.
And then they get in -- too
many of them get in trouble.
We need to -- if you're going to
spend billions of dollars on war,
spend a couple of billion, put
it away, to build up your --
your resources here -- we've talked
about a lot of the resources --
for when the troops come back and
you know damn well that you're going
to have a lot of them who are
suffering from TBI, from PTSD,
from anxiety, from depression.
You got to help these guys
and be proactive in doing it.
>> Jonathan Elias: Greg?
>> Greg Crawford: Well,
first of all,
I want to thank you again Jonathon
for -- for being here today.
And I also want to point out
-- Bernie, you touched on it --
veterans typically will want to
help veterans and every single one
of these panel members I called
and there wasn't even a hesitation
that they wanted to help.
There wasn't a hesitation
from Melissa or Butch.
They wanted to be here.
And so what I would say to you is if
you're in a jurisdiction somewhere,
you got to find a champion and
don't take, "No," for an answer.
And there's a lot of help out
there for, um, folks that want
to implement some sort
of veterans programming.
There's a lot of resources
at your fingertips.
>> Jonathan Elias: I want
to thank the entire panel.
Thank you very much.
And just one parting thought
is, while you've heard a lot
of conversation about how it's
veterans talking to veterans,
I would implore folks,
especially in rural communities,
if you've got the gumption
and you're a civilian
and you care deeply about this
subject, these are our warriors
that we sent off to protect and --
and serve and sacrifice,
in many cases.
Then if you want open up
some sort of center like this
and help facilitate it, then,
by all means, please do.
You can call the numbers that
we've made available to you.
Go to the websites.
Look it up.
Put it together yourself.
It will make a huge difference.
You -- you actually
could save a life.
So, thank you very much for being
here and thank you for joining us.
[ Applause ]
>> Jonathan Elias: Thank you, buddy.
Thank you.
Thank you, Bernie.
>> Tom Berger: Good job, Tim.
>> Jonathan Elias:
Thank you very much.
Questions of the panel, please,
you can stay for a few minutes,
ask whatever you'd like.
>> I'm a Vietnam veteran and I'm --
I'm a mentor at the Fairfax
Virginia Veterans Court docket.
Um, I want to make one comment and
then maybe ask the judge a question.
The comment is, uh, our particular
veterans court docket was the first
in Virginia to get started.
Uh, it's been a slow process.
We've gotten a few people
through to graduate.
Um, one of the problems is
whether we have enough incentives
to offer troubled veterans
going through the program.
For example, there may be a few that
have multiple DUIs and some of them,
when they're presented with
the choice of whether to go
into the program or to serve
time, they decide to serve time
because their charges are
not expunged from the record
in the state of Virginia.
And that, I understand, in some of
the other veterans court dockets
in the country, expungement is a
possibility and is an incentive
to get troubled veterans
through the program.
The second issue, um, that I'd
like to hear you address, we've --
being the first veterans
court docket in Virginia,
we've gone to Richmond
to lobby politically
to expand the veterans court docket
program in the state and we run
into problems politically with
some of the committee chairmen,
many of them conservative,
who don't see the value
of the veterans court
docket programs.
They think, "Why give veterans
special treatment compared
to the rest of the population?"
And it's a major problem.
We'd love to see this program
expand throughout the state.
How do you deal with that?
How can we change some of
those political attitudes
in the state capitals?
>> Vance Peterson: It's -- it's --
I keep running into
that on a daily basis.
It's very difficult for me
to go to Olympia and ask
for any additional funding.
We fund most of our stuff locally.
But the question, you
know, why veterans courts?
I had a, oddly enough, public
defender come up to me and say,
you know, "Why do you want
to have a veterans court?
I mean, the next thing you know,
you're going to have a
special create for police
and a special court for
firemen, and, you know,
we already have a mental
health court.
We already have a drug court.
Why -- why do this?"
And, you know, it's --
veterans don't necessarily fit
into those systems.
And I -- one of my examples
I just used was, "OK.
In no other job in the world will
you have a 21 year old sergeant tell
a 20 year old private,
'There's gunfire over there.
Check it out.'" There's
no other job.
And after you have experienced
that, after you have gone
through that whole process,
you will never come back
and be a civilian again.
You will always be a veteran.
You might have a drug problem.
You might have a mental
health issue.
You might have TBI, PTSD,
they need that other court
because that other court --
that other court will
make them successful.
That recidivism rate in most
veteran's courts is like 11% to 13%.
The average recidivism
rate is over 40%.
These courts are successful.
These defendants, these mentees,
these veterans don't come back
after they've gone through
this program for the most part.
I mean, it's a hard push when
you're dealing with the guys
who hold the money, but they are
the ones that have to be convinced.
But if you can -- if you can
do it -- without that money,
if you started out on your own,
you can make them eat their words.
>> Greg Crawford: And I'd like
to reiterate that you've got
to find out your numbers.
You know, find out how many
veterans are in your system.
>> Vance Peterson: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Greg Crawford: Throughout
the state.
>> Tom Berger: Yeah.
We've had -- we've had, uh,
situations -- one state
in particular.
There have been a couple of, uh,
veterans treatment
courts been established
in several counties in Arizona.
And there are some where
they refuse to do it
because there aren't many
veterans living out in the desert
in those particular counties.
They can't justify it.
>> Vance Peterson: What we
do, though, I would note,
we set up the veterans
forums Spokane.
It's a 501(c)(3) and, again,
most veterans courts
have a 501(c)(3) set up,
a charitable organization so that
we can help fund some of the things
that the mentors do,
fund the mentor training.
Our court, our little court
in Spokane, Washington,
actually has seven other county
courts that feed into our forum.
So they're -- they're getting
that therapy through the --
the 501(c)(3) from
seven different courts.
Although, they may not even say
they have a veteran's court,
because they're a small
rural county,
they may have a guy who's
a veteran who's on a docket
that they will send into
that particular program.
>> What about the issue
of expungement?
>> Vance Peterson: Uh, DUIs became
a very big issue in my county
and when I tried to set this thing
up, the prosecutor was adamant
that we will not dismiss DUIs.
You -- if you get a DUI and
it's reduced, it will still stay
at a reduced level,
perhaps a negligent driving
or inattentive driving, but it was
a very hot bed political issue.
The prosecutor is generally
the gatekeeper.
The elected prosecutor is generally
the guy who's going to lose his job
if he looks soft on crime.
So you really kind of have to
do a delicate waltz with them.
Fortunately, the prosecutor
in my county
at the time was an Air Force
veteran and he was willing to, uh --
to offer the deals
and offer the -- uh --
op his prosecutor to spend that
time in the veteran's court.
>> Unfortunately, we're out of time.
Thank you all very
much for attending.
Um, I hope you learned something
and I hope you take something
back to your communities.
Um, thank you to all of our
panelists, to our hosts,
to our speakers, to our moderator.
Thank you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.